The analytical problem solving
framework that we just outlined
will help us systematically work
our way through a business problem.
However, it doesn't help us
understand which methodology to use.
To determine the methodology, we're
going to reference the following flow
chart, which we'll refer
to as the Methodology Map.
The Methodology Map will help us as
we decide which problem to use for
our business problem.
And is meant to be used as we work our
way through the analytical problem
solving framework provided
in the previous lesson.
Let's start at the top
of the flow chart.
The first step is to determine
if the business problem
involves predicting an outcome or not.
Having a solid understanding
of the business issue
and data will help us easily
answer this question.
Earlier, we discussed a scenario
where we needed to predict
the electricity supply capacity.
After working through the business
issue, we decided that we also need to
predict the temperature of
each hour of the day as well.
For this scenario,
we'd go down the path to the left.
For many problems, some basic data
analysis methodologies will be enough.
For these types of analysis,
we proceed down the path to the right.
Let's first summarize some types
of non-predictive data analysis.